tous les gens qui sont dehors merci à la
police d'être plat pour nous aider il
n'y a pas que des crapuleux à la police
il ya un port sans même pas 1 % des
coûts les deux policiers qui se comporte
mal et tous les policiers viennent les
condamnés sur les plateaux télé donc ce
que vous dites là c'est vraiment une
caricature ce genre de photos de
reportage parce que il se trimballe pour
le sécuriser vous pensez bien qu'ils
sont pas là en train de menacer des
jeunes mais ne rentrer chez eux et de
l'armée attend chez lui c'est important
de le dire oui mais voilà je suis désolé
c'est la dernière partie de l'année
merci nourdine réveille toi nicolas t'as
vu la scène ils sont pas en train de se
de se trimballer pour protéger dans
l'attentât et sont là seulement cela
mais pour dire aux gens ici au protocole
en fait et c'est bien comme ça les
protocoles depuis son siège en dehors
avec ses normes comme ça en faisant
entrer chez jamais protocole de la peur
la devanture allons faire comme si j'en
suis désolé non alors c'est la vérité et
la république hors marché la république
de la peur et de la répression n'a rien
écouté par son mari et je vais vous dire
la vérité à l'histoire au chaud et au
pardon ok vous s'il vous plaît moi je
voulais dire un truc c'est que je vois
les réactions sur les réseaux sociaux et
beaucoup de gens qui sont d'accord avec
olive olive donc c'est à beaucoup de
gens qui disent voilà que c'est vrai que
c'est ils ont l'impression que c'est
disproportionné
donc vous dites qu'on est en plan
vigipirate c'est serré mais c'est vrai
que quand on voit cette image c'est vrai
que pour le policier c'est gênant et
pour la la foule aussi du transit mais
ils patrouillent dans des rues où
effectivement il ya des terrasses
ouvertes pour protéger les gens ensuite
je crois que c'est beaucoup l'amalgamé
entre cette image et les événements qui
ont pu avoir lieu à rennes et encore une
fois on fait une faute
un focus très importante sur ce qui
s'est passé à rennes il ya peut-être une
dispersion malencontreuse de la part des
forces de l'ordre il ya aussi je suis
désolé le déconfinement il se passera
bien parce que ça à la fois tout le
monde joue le jeu et c'est ce qu'on
appelle la responsabilité individuelle
on a mis des règles on ne trouve que ce
sont des bonnes règles ou des mauvaises
blagues
chacun peut avoir son à un arbitrage
dessus mais il ya un couvre-feu à 21h
consultons mais il ya un couvre-feu à
21h avec des règles par exemple si ce
portable quand vous êtes dans un resto
c'est pas le déconfinement c'est pas
l'ouverture de fête géante
ça peut agacer sur peu frustré mais il
faut que tout le monde tienne serre est
parce qu à côté
justement vous disiez il ya une personne
dont on accueille une personne dans une
véranda
on risque de fermeture administrative
c'est moi j'ai des restaurateurs sur ma
circonscription
ça fait plus de presque plus d'un an
qu'ils ont pas pu travailler ou alors
ils travaillent en dématérialisé à
travers des plateformes de livraison ils
sont frustrés ils sont en souffrance eh
bien ils n'ont pas envie de voir parce
que leurs collègues ne tient pas la
règle de devoir refermer dans deux mois
comme des sirènes je suis désolé je sais
c'est que je sais ça non mais la raison
là dessus marie donc les magpies
mots-clés mec joue il faut que les mecs
jouent le jeu si l'on sera refermée dans
deux mois va être un grand bal olive
olive laurent baujard rien à rajouter
là-dessus mais à chaque finirait
là-dessus mois par rapport à ça c'est on
pense que ces règles sont bonnes mais
arrêtez de penser demandé un peu aux
citoyens ce qu'ils en pensent eux parce
que normalement vous êtes là à l'écouté
citoyens vous n'êtes pas là pour décider
de vos rêves mais rassurez-vous il
fallait beaucoup de temps sur le banc
comme ça non mais arrêtez généré minutes
chez moi ça marche même pas bons mais je
passe beaucoup de temps sur le terrain
sur ma circonscription voile on passe
autant avec les personnes qui sont des
citoyens citoyens dit ce que vous les
aimez mais jamais non mais on n'écoute
jamais qu'on a voté pour quelqu'un qui
doit capter son programme mais non mais
j'essaie de comprendre la colère d'olive
olives
c'est quand même et elle vous n'êtes pas
de la récession vivre en france il
répond que vous vivez dans l'un des plus
beaux pays du rendez vous
les dpu vous parlerai même pas
enclenchée au gouvernement
laissez moi on va continuer parce ap et
en réponse et pour ça on prend pas cette
colère en fait cet énorme après celle de
l'âge et expliquer pourquoi tu la
comprends pas parce que moi ça fait
trois ans que je suis dans la rue et toi
tu sais pas ce que c'est la rue vas-y
ruiz et la paix dans la réalité de
l'apprendre non mais moi je connais la
réalité de la france parce que vous êtes
complètement déconnecté moins dépendant
des coiffeurs enfin région du shropshire
pêche